[Music]
Democratic and Republican lawmakers are
condemning the center-back
chants that erupted during President
Trump rally in North Carolina this week
the phrase has been labeled ugly wrong
and racist the president is trying to
distance himself from it the words echo
America's long and painful history of
telling US citizens of color they do not
belong here
we spoke to three Americans who have had
those words spoken to them
twenty-five-year-old in CEA's ad is a
sales trader fifty year old Michael Lee
is a lawyer originally from Texas and 42
year-old Sylvia Manrique is a marketing
professional all were born in America I
have been told countless times to go
back to my country so many times that I
can't even remember everybody has a
story right this is not something that
is in any way unusual this is like
everybody's experience phrases like
speak English this is America to have to
be reminded this is America it's like
Hello
I know it's America I was born here
sometimes they were just questions about
like where are you from and I would say
I'm from Dallas and then people would
say well you know I mean really where
are you from it's like Oklahoma
originally I was chasing this very thing
that wouldn't accept me at the same time
I was leaving behind parts of my Indian
heritage I had asked my parents to stop
packing the Indian lunches that my white
counterparts told me smelled too bad
I shouldn't have to justify my existence
here I shouldn't have to justify that
you know I belong here but sometimes you
just have to say it and I'm just as
American as anyone else it really comes
as a sucker punch and remind you that
like gosh you know maybe your place in
this country isn't quite as secure as
you you think it's and that's in some
ways frightening
[Applause]
the crowd was talking about sending her
back for criticizing the US and you know
when you think about Bernie Sanders he's
pretty criticizes America every day and
nobody ever tells him to go back to
where he came from now I feel fearful
for my peers of color
I feel fearful for children of
immigrants I feel fearful for immigrants
I think it really elevates this to a
different level this country has been
amazing to us and yet you know like I
think a lot of people have had thoughts
over the last few years like like what
if this doesn't last I mean what if this
isn't somehow permanent
you can't put all Americans into a
spreadsheet and run an equation and say
well you're more American than me
because your ancestors have been here
longer than mine
what's all this though you're either
American or you're not its citizenship
is just a yes or no question
people love this country and and like
you know I think the idea that this
country only belongs to some people you
know I think we need to like flee from
that us please we can they're either
American you're not citizenship is a yes
or no question yes what a great piece
just that insight and it makes me think
back to when you were Cape Canaveral and
the astronaut saying when you look down
yes at the world and you realize that
we're all here hopefully to thrive yeah
so we we need to get along it's in our
best interest to do so we are one is the
message from the US and we need to
support each other and again all for
those congresswoman are American
citizens three born here